I get the feeling in your life there
wasn't ever a man
who didn't want something from you like
you never had you've never experienced
the kind of love or support
where there's no sexual agenda or some
quid pro quo you know yeah I was even
thinking about this part of your life
where you know you go right to Playboy
you're in Hefner's mansion and then even
when they wanted to hire you on Baywatch
and they wanted to if they had to
contact the Playboy Mansion to get you
like you didn't even have the proper
representation
Hefner wasn't looking out for you Hefner
made money off of you uh as many people
did the Baywatch posters everything else
you were a marketable item and I think
everyone saw you that way
and you never had the kind of
representation
like your contract with Baywatch should
have been negotiated by
someone in a professional relationship
who didn't want to be sexual with you or
want to make money off of you and in
some inappropriate way am I correct
well yeah and Mike and it's funny
because my kids are very obviously very
protective of me and they think how
could this happen I mean Brandon was
just looking at my Baywatch residuals
and you know he was like you make like a
thousand dollars a year let me watch
residuals like in total right um how's
that possible why Why did um Playboy
represent you on your deal with Baywatch
and stuff like that like married with
children with everything because the
only place the only way people could get
a hold of me it was through Playboy I
didn't have an agent
and so why did I need an agent I didn't
think I was going to be an actress I
thought I was going home any minute I
was gonna I'll stay here as long as I'm
working and it just kept on going
see that makes me angry because Playboy
had no business representing you on your
contracts that you started I'm sure
there was at some point there were
lawyers and things involved but just the
very beginning you know you don't expect
to
um have a career as an actress I don't
know I wasn't that wasn't even on the
list of things to do I wasn't sure uh
what was going to happen So eventually
yeah you do get representation
and I know I had that again number three
selling Mattel toy like the Barbie but I
didn't get anything from those kind of
things it drives me insane I mean why
why didn't you Amazon Prime you know now
streams Baywatch I don't get anything
for that but we didn't have any you know
like there was no such thing as
streaming back then we there's four
channels I mean I'm back in the you know
ABC NBC CBS FOX we didn't have
syndication and Baywatch was one of the
first indicated shows so it wasn't like
friends where they were making millions
an episode it was it was um just before
that
foreign